Middle Eastern father immigrant came
here with nothing there was never an
illusion that work was not required to
get to where you wanted to go the moment
were really shifted though I was
probably in college everything had come
easy to me school-wise I did really well
but in college I went to Vanderbilt and
everyone there was really smart I just
always expected I could just not save
for anything and like I would Ace it and
I didn't have that happen and so I ended
up going fall break with like a 1-0 and
so he was like hey I'm just not going to
keep you in school if this is what's
going to happen so I didn't go out
didn't do anything for the remainder of
the semester and I think I finished with
a 3-2 I basically got an A on every
single assignment from that point bar
was set it was probably the moment
though where I tied hours of work to
outcome and then that just became my Mo
like everyone knew it was like hermosis
in class at the library at the gym or at
the cafeteria four things from nine to
nine every day